6/3
dégagez vous l'aimez ce mario là alors
oui avant les cellulaires avant les
tablettes la façon de montrer son côté
branché technos était avec sa montre
rappelez vous du temps où l'on comparé
parfois entre nous les différentes
fonctions de nos montres et dans le lot
le feu dufait la l'himalaya de la montre
branché c'était la montre calculatrice
est à même parfois doublée d'un agenda
électronique sonic ce fait longtemps sur
la fin longtemps la première du genre
c'était une pulsar c'était en 1975
repérez peut-être elle s'est montrée la
wii elle était pourvue de dire d'électro
luminescence rouge on les aimait james
bond on avait une dent vivre et laisser
mourir le matin à poitiers il y avait
donc sur ces premières montres
calculatrice de tout petits boutons il
fallait un stylet imaginez les premiers
modèles de la pulsion il était en ordre
se vend des 4000 $ aux bonbons aux
pièces oui mais bon le modèle grand
public c'est une cinquantaine de chars
220 dollars aujourd'hui et quand on
ajuste les prix il ya vraiment fallu sap
à décoller ses premiers modèles l'oeil a
vraiment fallu attendre que castillo et
ses costumes est hélas il ya pas mal de
gens qui en ont possédé d'ailleurs si
vous connaissez vous quelqu'un qui n'est
venu chercher quelqu'un qui veuille plus
arles avec les diodes rouges et tout et
tout mon paraît avait ressurgi sur cetet
il était cool c'est pour ce pour ça que
c'était le top du top dans les premiers
modèles calculatrice et toul avec le
style est là donc est-ce que vous est-ce
que vous l'aviez seuil et n'ont jamais
vu le bruit j'avais pu le jouer avec
quelques minutes juste très réservé au
grand bruit donc c'est les montres qui
ont connu quelques moments de gloire
on n'a qu'à vous entende rappelez vous
quand même du personnage de marty mcfly
dans retour vers le futur qui en
arborait une notre invité d'aujourd'hui
a toujours là sierro et il apporte
encore acheté en 1988 pour 125 $ c'est
steve ouellette qui est enseignant en
mathématiques
sciences et technologies au lac saint
jean ce parce qu'on l'a joint par
téléphone j'ai trouvé en faisant un
appel de candidatures sur facebook on
écoute nous parler de sa montre son sol
1988 la première montée avec la triste
et c'est même ma soeur et je le suis
encore
premièrement le magasin qui va adresse
assez fermé c'était distribution aux
consommateurs un jonquière au saguenay
et moi je suis très attaché à mes objets
il fait très attention à mes choses je
lisais très longtemps puis se fondent
d'arriver à quelque part les gens qu'est
ce que c'est que tu en as encore se
montrer que la crise est organisée
depuis qu'un kg soit depuis 25 ans mon
ami c'est très plaisant à voir sans moi
j'aime savoir les bien il a faim il est
conservé longtemps plaie garder belle
douce est maintenant contre multitouch
moi j'avais besoin d'un agenda
électronique
il avait besoin de dix mètres mes
contacts c'est les les ipod iphone ça
n'existait pas à ce moment ries palme
exister même pas encore c'était mon
agenda
c'était ma calculatrice c'était mon
baptême numéro de téléphone
c'était pour par exemple calculer les
taxes calculer les rabais dans les
magasins et pourcentage numéro de
téléphone donc j'avais je vais axer mon
bâton surtout pour les frais quand on
oublie les fêtes c'est vraiment choquant
qui c'était la seule façon de ne pas
penser tout ça était présentement les
boutons est très petit on appuie avec
les angles sur les boutons et même que
les boutons actuellement les boutons le
non plus leur leurs chiffres et qui le
les chiffres de couleur blanc sont
partis mais je peux lire quand même les
par le relief qu'il le creusage les
boutons vous
avant c'est une chose qui est quand même
assez intéressante c'est que d'avoir de
l'information au poignet ça reste
quelque chose qui est pertinent oui oui
parce qu'une montre on a toujours sur
nos vingt quatre heures sur vingt quatre
tandis que le cellulaire vont à la pêche
je le connais seulement la débauche et
aussi matière 10 de la consommation et
on rangera les distributions
consommateur est toujours une autre
chronique tête l'an prochain on
attendait donc six voiliers de dire que
l'information au poignet reste pratique
ce pauvre marié qu on attend la watch et
le retour des montres lui toutes ces
montres connecter la et attendiez-vous à
ce qu'il y en ait de plus en plus au
cours des prochains mois parce que dans
les expositions spécialisées comme le cs
a notamment las vegas en début d'année
on en a vu vraiment plusieurs modèles il
yaa potier a annoncé la sienne pour le
mois d'octobre à peu près où on va
mettre beaucoup l'accent sur des
fonctions en lien avec la santé et
l'entraînement faudra voir la suite va
être excitant qui est quelque chose qui
me dit que le poignet a pas dit son
dernier mot mais de toute façon c'est
moi j'ai montré très society là c'est la
première fonction c'est vrai oui merci
beaucoup